we're proud of it you can look back in
10 years and be like yes the harmony is
gearing up to release their second album
7/27 on May 20th but during the
recording process there are loyal fans
of the Harmonizers fear to break up when
Camila Kibeho skyrocketed to the top of
the charts apart from the group and with
Shawn Mendes
I have said you're not splitting up this
record is very much proof of that how
could that affect you guys and what kind
of conversations happen I mean we were
just in the studio and we are coming out
with an album now so there you go that's
what happened with that honestly at the
end of the day this harmony is
definitely our first love so I've always
been the foundation of everything so
regardless of everything that's been
going on oh it's always been focused
behind me mm-hmm and you guys see
another album after this one can you
predict the future I can't predict the
future but we most definitely think that
there will be last year at this time one
direction who also formed on the
x-factor though in the UK lost one of
its members
Zayn Malik months later the band
announced a break
ironically the girls reveal the advice
band member Harry Styles told them I
remember we were we were in rehearsals
and he came up to us and told us as a
group you all all five of you should be
on the same page and the closest things
to each other because around all five of
them they're gonna be people that gonna
come and try to snatch you people are
going to try to break you guys apart so
as long as you as long as you five are
your best friends that's the most
important and the girls are adamant the
group comes first and so does giving
back this week they teamed up with urban
Fitness nine-one-one to share stories
and advice with at-risk youth
you will choose where you want to be
requirement if you never lose sight of
the way it is we just hope that these
these kids are inspired afterwards you
know that you know it doesn't matter
where you come from just like all of us
you can go for your dreams you're gonna
be obstacles but you can do it so don't
let anything hold you back